it's so good to see both of you and talk
about a tear jerker for the holidays it
is such a beautiful film and i remember
the time when saul and jen got married
in toronto at casa loma in 2015. so this
is a very important story to us in
canada
and to see you bring it to life is so
important so jessica did you have a
chance to talk to jen
after the film and how did she respond
to it
i did um i am so lucky that
i was able to be in communication with
jen before we started filming
throughout the shoot she actually came
to visit us on set
and then um we actually touched base i
guess maybe
a week or two ago and she just loves the
movie and is so
overjoyed i think because we all talked
about that at the end of the day the
most important thing that we wanted to
really put into the world
was how unique and special and filled
with love
their relationship was and what it's
like
to fall in love with your best friend
even if the time you have together is
cut short
and so i i think that even though
in the script there are things that are
different from the real
life story and and there were some
liberties taken that it's still
honors saul it honors their love and it
honors
how brave and um
and strong both of them were in the face
of adversity
and the timing was interesting i mean
you were planning your wedding she was
there during the wedding vow
scene you're mary congratulations thank
you
at a time like this yeah it was
a total a kind of brain
pretzel puzzle um to be planning a
wedding and shooting a wedding
and writing fake vows and then writing
my real vows like there was a lot of
very strange questions
your fake husband on the show husband
marrying my
real maybe fake husband i don't know
where i am um
but the thing i have to say is it was
such a
gift to go through this experience with
harry
and our incredible director mark and the
crew and the cast
and to learn all of those lessons kind
of in a crash course
and then go into my real life and that's
one of the things i'm so grateful to
this movie for is i learned
so much about love and commitment and
being strong
and um and positivity and
and moving through the world with
gratitude and that's something that i'm
trying to
put in my life every day whether it's in
my real wedding or just
when i'm sitting on the couch so i love
that and harry i have to say
it was so refreshing to see an asian
lead
in a role like this in a romantic movie
it's a pivotal moment i mean
how did your family and friends react to
you being in a film like this
and for yourself um you know it's
i i again like sharing what in gratitude
in in in a different way i
for for me it's it's the people who
paved the way
you know yeah you know i know in history
just in in hollywood just in general but
like you know you don't get this many
opportunities
just be a whole human being uh and not
not just a certain stereotype or uh
so but at the end of the day it's really
what it is is honoring
saul you know he's he yeah he's a larger
than life
uh person and and to be able to
to put this on on film and and to adapt
it in a way that
honors him is really special so i mean
uh and for for him it was a funny story
i remember jen told us that you know he
used to sit there and watch
what's glee together and yeah you know i
i was
a very background character and he they
would always joke like oh there's
there's an asian guy it's representation
so like
i used to do the same yeah the fact that
saul and jen watch this is kind of
a really cool full circle thing and i i
i
you know when jen sent the message to us
after she watches she's like
i think saul would be very proud and
that's what uh that's what um
really makes it special for us you know
one of my favorite scenes is actually in
the bar scene where you're trying to do
the
the rock eyebrow uh raised thing
and i was like and then i'm just sitting
there trying to do it myself
uh i understand the rock wants to be
part of crazy rich asians
is that going to happen in part two i
mean look if
if he uh if he said he wouldn't be part
of it i'm sure would speed up the
process
and then but um yeah you look i mean
look i think it's just such a cool
cool thing that how many people really
really want to
uh be part of it or just watch it and
see it so i'm a
i'm watching it as a fan too so i mean
to be part of it
it's kind of like pinching myself uh
it's uh and to be such a
part of a special cast and a phenomenon
are you guys shooting already for crazy
rich asians or no that
no they're they're yeah okay okay
okay soon but thank you so much to both
of you i can't wait for everyone to
watch this film it is something that we
do need in our lives and just having
that
i guess it really does explain how
important human connection really is so
i really appreciate thank you so much to
both of you